[Music]
this music has always been my dream well
dreams come true if you're Paris hilted
who just sang at her first ever concert
[Music]
yeah the veteran DJ had a pretty big
night on Wednesday love being around
that energy so being a DJ has been so
much fun but it was paris's onstage
vocal debut that brought out the
a-listers
God
[Music]
we've got Ashley Simpson and Elle
Fanning dropping these moments on their
Instagram stories
[Music]
while Elle's sister Dakota was a no-show
she later gushed to Paris on the gram so
bummed to have missed this you killed it
Queen
also in the crowd Dylan Mulvaney
meanwhile Paris was joined on stage by a
couple of Besties so Edie and Kim Petrus
check out the Grammy winner helping
Paris kick off what she's calling the
summer of slipping the new word it's
like the new that's hot it's slipping
living slivers for life
[Music]
of course the Hilton family stepped out
to celebrate paris's Milestone moment
too which doubled as a pride
month-themed fundraiser dad Rick kept
the praise simple in his post so proud
of my daughter the first person I always
ask advice from is my sister she always
tells me the truth and truth is that
Nikki couldn't wait to see her big sis
take the stage well Mom Kathy cheered
Paris on next to her Housewives co-star
set in Strack
yes
[Music]
good night
Ferris later admitted she was brought to
Tears by all the support telling her
fans the love I felt in that room was so
incredible I feel like the luckiest girl
in the world we're just so excited to
throw our life together in the future
yep there's nothing simple about her
newlywed life with husband Carter Reen
after the couple welcomed their son
Phoenix in January who was quickly
followed by another kind of baby two
months later the reality Stars book
Paris the Memoir I thought it was time
to really just tell my true story and
now she's adding more chapters to her
fairy tale life starting with living out
her pop star dreams
yeah
[Music]
it's all about just having a good time
being yourself
and having fun you only live once
foreign